其他人:给你一拳
Others: Give you a punch.
Jake:走走走走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Shure: 呃呃
Shure: Uh, uh.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: This is it.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 呃呃哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Uh, uh, hahahahahaha.
Shure: 然后有的时候还打完啊啊啊的跑对
Shure: And sometimes after hitting, we run, right?
Jake:你要穿
Jake: You need to wear...
Jake:你要穿模
Jake: You need to clip through.
Jake:你会穿模吗
Jake: Can you clip through?
Shure: 我这穿模有点费劲
Shure: It's a bit tricky for me to clip through.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
其他人:我操这是他妈的这个沙雕
Others: Damn, this is so fucking stupid.
其他人:抖音上的短视频居然出现我眼前
Others: A TikTok short video actually appeared before my eyes.
Lucia:哈哈刚应该给你俩录一下的
Lucia: Haha, we should have recorded you two just now.
其他人:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:都录了录着了录着了
Jake: We did, we recorded it all.
Jake:都有我第一视角就沙雕
Jake: Got it all, from my first-person view, hilarious.
Lucia:也行我好
Lucia: Yeah, that works, I'm good.
其他人:哈哈我好奇我们到时候音频要喘吗
Others: Haha, I'm curious, will we need to pant for the audio later?
Jake:传啊这个都传
Jake: Of course, we'll include it all.
其他人:我总感觉这音频要自己
Others: I feel like we'll need to clean this audio ourselves.
其他人:这音频到时数据一清洗
Others: Once the data is cleaned...
其他人:全洗完了
Others: It'll be all gone.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：洗的残缺不全
Others: Cleaned till it's all incomplete.
Shure: 还有什么比较适合走啊
Shure: What else is suitable for walking?
Shure: 这个也适合
Shure: This works too.
Katrina: 有点像跳popping的
Katrina: Looks a bit like popping.
Katrina: 哈哈什么都精通啊就说
Katrina: Haha, you're proficient in everything, huh?
Shure: 那我妹会跳braking
Shure: My sister can breakdance.
Katrina: 真假真牛
Katrina: Really? That's impressive.
Jake:缺点墨镜这倒是
Jake: Missing some sunglasses, though.
Shure: （歌词）叱咤风云我任意闯万众仰望
Shure: (Lyrics) Dominating the world, I roam freely, admired by all.
Shure: 迪士尼
Shure: Disney.
Jake:这些车牌号都得干掉
Jake: We need to blur out these license plates.
Jake:我靠哈哈好烦呐
Jake: Damn, so annoying.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：OCR对啊对啊
Others: OCR, right, right.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:就要干掉嘛
Jake: We need to blur them out.
其他人：我昨天还看季风带在朋友圈发
Others: I saw Monsoon posting on WeChat Moments yesterday.
其他人：他用那个英特VL啊
Others: He used that Intel VL.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后两辆车
Others: And then two cars...
其他人：一辆宝马一辆奔驰啊
Others: A BMW and a Mercedes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后那个标就是那种巨小的那种
Others: And the logo was super small.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后他就问英特VL说
Others: Then he asked Intel VL about...
其他人：这辆这个宝马车的车牌号是多少啊
Others: The license plate number of the BMW.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
其他人：他会卧槽
Others: He will say "wow"
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
其他人：OK非常的厉害
Others: OK, very impressive
Shure: 我们是不是应该穿个膜什么的
Shure: Should we put on some kind of cover?
其他人：你这时候应该往这走
Others: You should go this way now
其他人：就卡在这个地方
Others: Just get stuck here
其他人：卡在这卡
Others: Stuck here
Jake:你卡在两侧中间对
Jake: You're stuck in the middle between both sides, right?
其他人： 卡进去卡在这个火中间
Others: Stuck in the middle of the fire
其他人：对
Others: Yes
Shure: 或者NF直接进入再去吧
Shure: Or NF directly enters and then goes
Shure: 我们还是
Shure: We still
其他人：可以录我一段
Others: Can record a segment of me
其他人：这应该怎么搞
Others: How should this be done?
Jake:谢丽哈哈
Jake: Shelly haha
Jake:谢丽哈哈哈哈哈哈一路抖音吗
Jake: Shelly hahaha, all the way on Douyin?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 下去吧你
Shure: Go down, you
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: （歌词）他们朝我扔泥巴
Shure: (Lyrics) They throw mud at me
Shure: （歌词）我拿泥巴种荷花
Shure: (Lyrics) I plant lotuses with the mud
Lucia:从未觉得这么平凡的一条路
Lucia: Never thought such an ordinary road
Lucia:能有这么多的危险
Lucia: Could have so many dangers
Shure: 平凡的路
Shure: Ordinary road
Shure: 这平凡吗
Shure: Is this ordinary?
Lucia:平凡吗不平凡吗
Lucia: Ordinary? Not ordinary?
Shure: 我曾经跨过山和大海
Shure: I once crossed mountains and seas
Lucia:也走过人山人海
Lucia: Also walked through crowds of people
Shure: 我曾经拥有过的一切
Shure: I once had everything
Lucia:忘了哈哈哈
Lucia: Forgot it, hahaha
Shure: （歌词）我曾经像你像他
Shure: (Lyrics) I once was like you, like him
Shure: （歌词） 像那野草野花
Shure: (Lyrics) Like the wild grass and flowers
Shure: 这个口音一定要模仿到位
Shure: This accent must be mimicked perfectly
其他人：知道看见平凡
Others: Know and see ordinary
Shure:   朴树
Shure: Pu Shu
Shure: （歌词）所有的灯的灯都挂了
Shure: (Lyrics) All the lights are out
Shure: （歌词）所有牛逼过的都退了所有
Shure: (Lyrics) Everyone who was awesome has left
Shure: （歌词）birthday to you
Shure: (Lyrics) Birthday to you
Shure: （歌词）happy birthday
Shure: (Singing) Happy birthday
Jake:走我们去我们去给他们祝贺一下
Jake: Let's go, let's go congratulate them.
Shure: （歌词）to you
Shure: (Singing) To you
Shure: （歌词）happy birthday to you
Shure: (Singing) Happy birthday to you
Shure: （歌词）今天你生日
Shure: (Singing) Today is your birthday
Shure: （歌词）送给你祝福
Shure: (Singing) Sending you blessings
其他人:（歌词）哒哒哒我们相亲又相爱
Others: (Singing) Da da da, we are close and love each other
Shure: 幸福美满
Shure: Happiness and harmony
Shure: （歌词）跟所有的烦恼说bye bye
Shure: (Singing) Say bye bye to all the troubles
其他人：（歌词）跟所有的快乐说嗨嗨
Others: (Singing) Say hi hi to all the joy
Shure: （歌词）说嗨嗨
Shure: Say hi hi
Jake:我错了哈哈哈哈
Jake: My bad, hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈啊哈哈过了吗
Lucia: Hahaha, did we get it?
Shure: 喂喂喂哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hey hey hey, hahaha
Jake:没有没有他错了
Jake: No, no, he got it wrong.
Jake:对了对了对了哈哈
Jake: Alright, alright, alright, haha
Lucia:行大家都是社交恐怖分子是吧
Lucia: So, everyone is a social terrorist, huh?
其他人：我其实是哀人
Others: Actually, I'm a sad person.
Jake:对我我我们一排爱人
Jake: Yeah, we are all a row of lovers.
Lucia:真的哈哈
Lucia: Really, haha
Shure: 我也是哀人
Shure: Me too, I'm a sad person.
Lucia:我们可爱人
Lucia: We are cute people.
Jake:哈哈哈你觉得我信吗哈哈
Jake: Haha, do you think I believe you? Haha
Lucia:哈哈你觉得我信吗哈哈
Lucia: Haha, do you think I believe you? Haha
Shure: 月亮月
Shure: Moon moon
Jake:月亮
Jake: Moon
Shure: （歌词）呀嘛更儿里呀
Shure: (Singing) Yama genger liya
Shure: （歌词） 月牙儿照花台
Shure: (Singing) Crescent moon shines on the flower terrace
Jake:耶唱歌呢
Jake: Yay, singing
其他人：我靠
Others: Oh my
其他人：黑哥已经开
Others: Heige already started
Shure: 游戏一场
Shure: Just a game
Jake:对今儿周末应该挺多是闲人
Jake: Yeah, it's the weekend, there should be a lot of idle people.
Shure: （歌词）抛在脑后
Shure: (Singing) Throw it to the back of your mind
Katrina: 你为啥去安河桥啊
Katrina: Why did you go to Anhe Bridge?
Shure: （歌词）早知如此何必开始
Shure: (Singing) If I had known, why start
其他人：建议你进去跟他一起跳一会
Others: Suggest you go in and dance with him for a while
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人：我们回来接你
Others: We'll come back to pick you up
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 我怕你们不接我了
Shure: I was afraid you wouldn't take me in.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈那问题也不大是不是
Jake: Hahaha, then it's not a big deal, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:这么大个人了
Lucia: You're such a big guy.
Lucia:反正不会丢
Lucia: You won't get lost anyway.
Shure: 我怕
Shure: I'm scared.
其他人：黑完再去找我们
Shure: 我怕我怕我怕我怕
Shure: I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
Shure: 我的屁股不保
Shure: My butt is in danger.
Shure: 干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: 谢宾主你要你要你要你要
Shure: Thank you, Binzhu, you want, you want, you want.
Shure: 今天晚上你要亲我屁股哈哈哈
Shure: Tonight you have to kiss my butt, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what are you talking about?
其他人：我操这是能录的吗
Others: Damn, can this be recorded?
Jake:记一下记一下记一下记一下记一下
Jake: Note it, note it, note it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈秀秀这单你自己解
Jake: Hahaha, Shure, you handle this on your own.
其他人：这是可以录的吗
Others: Can this be recorded?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia:左拐啊左拐
Lucia: Turn left, turn left.
其他人：我们要剪的就全全额保留了
Others: We should keep everything we need to edit.
其他人:你们要剪就都保留走
Others: If you want to edit, keep it all.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
其他人：到时候就是语音识别问题
Others: Then it will be a speech recognition issue.
其他人:这一段你说呗
Others: You say this part.
Jake:他收音挺好的
Jake: The recording is good.
Shure: 真的吗真的吗
Shure: Really, really?
Jake:呵呵呵对
Jake: Hehe, yes.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake:因为他就在你脸上了
Jake: Because it's right in front of your face.
Shure: 那我
Shure: Then I...
其他人：18:50 11修硕体质10九点零六修硕逆天
Others: 18:50, 11 Shure's physique, 10 Shure's defiance at 9:06.
Shure: 那刚
Shure: Then just...
其他人:12:21危险言论
Others: 12:21, dangerous speech.
Lucia:我正在迅速复盘
Lucia: I'm quickly reviewing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈危险言论
Jake: Hahaha, dangerous speech.
Lucia:我有没有说过什么
Lucia: Did I ever say anything?
Lucia:哈哈不适合的我忘记了
Lucia: Haha, I forgot what I said wasn't suitable.
Jake:不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Jake:到时候看吧
Jake: We'll see later.
Shure: 慢慢消吧你们就
Shure: You guys just take your time to digest.
Jake:对慢慢削吧
Jake: Yeah, take your time.
Shure: 我只负责生产数据
Shure: I only handle data production.
Shure: 不负责处理数据
Shure: Not responsible for data processing.
Shure: 提上裤子就
Shure: Just pull up your pants and...
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 没事没事哈哈
Shure: It's fine, it's fine, haha.
Jake:擅长生产无用数据哈哈哈
Jake: You're good at producing useless data, haha.
Jake:又有小车
Jake: Another little car.
Shure: use protection
Shure: Use protection.
Jake:准备FFF FF
Jake: Ready FFF FF.
Shure: not use protection
Shure: Not use protection.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Jake:先拿一下站嘴边
Jake: First take it, put it by your mouth.
Jake:然后会停
Jake: Then it will stop.
Jake:就是我们的姐姐
Jake: It's our sister.
Jake:哈喽这是
Jake: Hello, this is...
其他人：这是带我们的
Others: This is our courier.
其他人：对对就是送快递的姐姐
Others: Yes, yes, the delivery sister.
Tasha: 在冰箱里
Tasha: In the fridge.
Shure: 这姐不会看的
Shure: This sister won't even look.
Shure: 他直接会撞过去的
Shure: She'll just crash into it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他每次坐车库库开着就玩手机
Shure: Every time she drives, she's just on her phone.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
其他人:你这个动作不对
Others: That's not the right move.
其他人：他带我说是两个手在玩
Others: She told me to use both hands.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:你动作太保守了
Lucia: Your moves are too conservative.
Jake:火
Jake: Fire.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure: 师傅捎一段吧
Shure: Master, give us a ride.
Shure: 咱们应该打车过去的
Shure: We should take a cab.
Shure: 打辆商务哈哈哈
Shure: Get a business vehicle, haha.
Lucia:23456确实哈
Lucia: 23456, really
Shure: 反正有经费嘿嘿
Shure: Anyway, we have the budget, hehe
Shure: ha ha
Shure: 唉咱晚上做什么梦
Shure: Hey, what kind of dreams are we having tonight?
Jake:欢庆春节
Jake: Celebrating the Spring Festival
Shure: 这两天睡得不踏实
Shure: I haven't been sleeping well these days
其他人：不踏实昨天晚上没有陪你
Others: You haven't been sleeping well, didn't keep you company last night
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get lost
Shure: 你妈要躺我旁边我都得做噩梦
Shure: Even if your mom was lying next to me, I'd have nightmares
其他人：昨天晚上睡觉冻了吗
Others: Were you cold while sleeping last night?
Jake:我不知道OK
Jake: I don't know, OK
Jake:哈哈哈你不会我
Jake: Hahaha, you wouldn't
Shure: 你不你你不会
Shure: You wouldn't, you wouldn't
Jake:哈哈哈我真不知道
Jake: Hahaha, I really don't know
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure: 真不知道
Shure: Really don't know
Jake:哈哈哈我应该知道什么吧
Jake: Hahaha, should I know something?
Shure: 完了我应该知道什么吧
Shure: Oh no, should I know something?
其他人:因为我觉得我睡得很踏实啊
Others: Because I think I slept really well
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 我就是应该问健康
Shure: I should ask about health
Shure: 摸摸自己的屁股疼吗
Shure: Does your butt hurt?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Jake:你再挤一条
Jake: Say one more thing
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哎呀他得会这些东西
Shure: Oh man, he should know these things
Jake:哈哈哈你能不能不让学术
Jake: Hahaha, can you stop being so academic?
Shure: 这些我是我们
Shure: These are just
Shure: 人之常情
Shure: Human nature
Jake:这些做学术的人做这东西
Jake: Academic people doing these things
Shure: 做学术的人就没有吃喝拉撒吗难道
Shure: Do academic people not eat, drink, and relieve themselves?
Jake:有但是好像没有你说的这些东西
Jake: They do, but not like what you said
Shure: 开玩笑那罗罗罗丽岛是吧
Shure: Just kidding, it's like Roro Island, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
其他人:他妈的7.08-09全删完
Others: Damn it, delete everything from 7.08-09
Katrina: 把嘴巴捂住
Katrina: Cover your mouth
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 就揭开他们丑陋的面纱
Shure: Let's uncover their ugly veil.
Shure: 不要一个个当
Shure: Don't be fooled one by one.
Lucia:不要
Lucia: No.
Lucia:一个个我都不想出现在这个画符里了
Lucia: I don't want to appear in this frame anymore.
Shure: 反正我以后不搞学术
Shure: Anyway, I'm not doing academics anymore.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈我马上上班了
Shure: Haha, I'm starting work soon.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 人家都是时间点我这时间段是吧
Shure: Others have specific times, I have time periods, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
其他人：有点有点夸张有点夸张
Others: That's a bit exaggerated.
其他人：可以啊可以啊你唱歌吧怎么样啊
Others: Sure, sure, you sing then, how about it?
其他人：希望你唱歌好听
Others: Hope you sing well.
Jake:唱点能播的
Jake: Sing something that's broadcastable.
Shure: 唱啊能播的呀哈哈哈
Shure: Sing something broadcastable, haha.
Jake:哈哈完了哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, over, haha.
Shure: 能播的有啥来着没有
Shure: What's broadcastable? None.
Jake:没有
Jake: None.
Jake:曲库里面没有
Jake: Not in the song library.
Jake:不存在的
Jake: Doesn't exist.
Shure: 确实你要说播点不能播
Shure: Indeed, if you want something unbroadcastable,
Shure: 我一下能给你唱10首
Shure: I can sing you ten songs right away.
其他人:那你先唱吧我给你接着唱
Others: You sing first, I'll follow.
Shure: 别了然后咱们取快递
Shure: No, let's go pick up the package.
Shure: 步行取快递的这个珍贵影像就没了
Shure: The precious footage of us walking to pick up the package will be gone.
其他人:你不仅要顶你一个人的眼镜
Others: You not only have to carry your own glasses,
其他人：你要把这个眼镜一起剪
Others: You have to edit these glasses together.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 我不剪哈哈
Shure: I won't edit, haha.
Shure: 之后就开始删微信了
Shure: Then I'll start deleting WeChat contacts.
Jake:再见了哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Goodbye, hahaha.
Shure: 再见了家人们哈哈哈
Shure: Goodbye, family, haha.
Shure: （歌词）今天你生日送给你祝福
Shure: (Lyrics) Today is your birthday, sending you blessings.
Shure: （歌词）啦啦啦啦啦
Shure: (Lyrics) La la la la la.
Shure: （歌词）哎呦来了来了来了
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh, here it comes, here it comes.
Shure: 这是什么地啊
Shure: What place is this?
Shure: 这不会是一个
Shure: This won't be a...
Shure: 珐琅吧
Shure: Enamel, is it?
Lucia:工作室可能是的
Lucia: The workshop might be.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:里面有人
Jake: There's someone inside.
Shure: 有
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 可不是吗
Shure: Of course there is.
Shure: 居然有人
Shure: Can't believe there's someone.
Jake:有好几个人
Jake: There are a few people.
Shure: a few people
Shure: A few people?
Jake:呵嗯
Jake: Yep.
Jake:好这翻译的
Jake: This translation is...
Shure: 这翻译的就是信不信达雅吧
Shure: This translation is just... accurate, fluent, elegant, huh?
Shure: 就说很难很难信
Shure: I mean, really hard to believe.
Jake:这很难很难信
Jake: It's really hard to believe.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:很难不信达雅哈哈哈
Jake: Hard not to believe it's accurate, fluent, elegant, hahaha.
Shure: 真的我这可以实时转意
Shure: Really, I can translate in real-time.
Shure: 好吧OK
Shure: Alright, okay.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Sure thing.
Jake:如意看见没
Jake: Did you see that, Ruyi?
Jake:AF OK哈哈哈哈
Jake: AF OK, hahaha.
Shure: AF OK
Shure: AF OK.
Shure: 哈哈哈AFCOM行
Shure: Hahaha, AFCOM, alright.
Jake:吉祥
Jake: Lucky.
Shure: happy啊这个
Shure: Happy, huh?
Shure: 如意啊啊
Shure: Ruyi, huh?
Jake:啊吉祥如意
Jake: Ah, lucky and happy.
Shure: follow your heart
Shure: Follow your heart.
Lucia:是这边吧
Lucia: Is it this way?
其他人:我怎么感觉
Others: How do I feel...
其他人:都要走到那个什么卫生间了
Others: ...like we're heading to the bathroom?
Jake:就是那哦
Jake: It's just over there.
Lucia:哎卫生站是这样走的吗
Lucia: Hey, is the bathroom this way?
Shure: i feel like we almost arrived hospital
Shure: I feel like we almost arrived at the hospital.
Jake:哎锦州巷子里要
Jake: Ah, in the Jinzhou alley, you need to...
Lucia:是晚上所以
Lucia: It's nighttime, so...
其他人：昨天信誓旦旦的说有
Others: Yesterday, we were so sure there was...
Shure: 锦州烧
Shure: Jinzhou barbecue.
Shure: 要不我们来这吃吧
Shure: How about we eat here?
Jake:哈哈哈整点串吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's have some skewers.
Shure: 闻着好香啊
Shure: Smells so good.
Jake:要不带点串回去吧要不
Jake: How about we take some skewers back?
Shure: 哈哈没有烧烤
Shure: Haha, no barbecue.
Lucia:因为昨天那会已经是晚上了
Lucia: Because it was already evening by then.
Lucia:现在这个天色又不认识了
Lucia: Now it looks different again.
Shure: 闻着好香啊
Shure: Smells so good.
Jake:你昨天直接走过来也挺挺远我感觉
Jake: You walked quite a long way yesterday, I felt.
其他人:我草我也想吃
Others: Damn, I want to eat too.
Lucia:我总觉得
Lucia: I always feel like...
Lucia:我昨天走的时候好像没这么远
Lucia: It didn't seem so far when I walked yesterday.
Jake:主要旁边没别人
Jake: Mainly because there was no one around.
Lucia:哈哈不是哈哈哈不是真不是
Lucia: Haha, no, really, no.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
其他人：昨天昨天没有修硕
Others: Yesterday, there was no Shure.
Shure: 我不是应该让时间变得更快吗
Shure: Wasn't I supposed to make time go faster?
其他人:你让我们时间变得很欢乐
Others: You made our time really enjoyable.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Shure: 欢乐的时光不是总是短暂的吗
Shure: Happy times are always short, aren't they?
其他人:欢乐的时光对
Others: Happy times, indeed.
其他人：那你就想一下为什么吧
Others: Then think about why.
Lucia:他这小路挺多的
Lucia: There are many small paths here.
Lucia:可能昨天走的不是同一个小路
Lucia: Maybe we didn't take the same path yesterday.
Jake:就消耗比较大是吧
Jake: Just more exhausting, right?
其他人：有点累
Others: A bit tired.
Jake:对有点累
Jake: Yeah, a bit tired.
Jake:嘟哒嘟
Jake: Doo-da-doo.
Shure: 挺好挺好
Shure: Pretty good, pretty good.
Shure: 我今天放弃了
Shure: I gave up today.
其他人：买个彩票
Others: Buy a lottery ticket.
Jake:羊汤馆
Jake: Lamb soup shop.
Shure: 卧槽对买了彩票
Shure: Damn, right, buy a lottery ticket.
Shure: 走走走这个珍贵录像得记录一下
Shure: Let's go, let's document this precious moment.
Shure: 啊这我真买着
Shure: Ah, I really bought it.
Jake:真买彩票
Jake: Really bought a lottery ticket.
Jake:看看看你刮彩票买买买
Jake: Look, look, scratch the ticket, buy, buy, buy.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 要来一个
Shure: Want to get one?
Shure: 这个 2020
Shure: This one, 2020.
其他人：就来50呗
Others: Just get 50.
Shure: 20就行
Shure: 20 is fine.
其他人:5050 来就来
Others: 5050, let's do it.
其他人:大的怎么这么少报销呢
Others: How come the big ones get so little reimbursement?
Shure: 报销吗
Shure: Reimbursement?
其他人:报销不报啊
Others: Aren't we getting reimbursed?
Jake:报销刮彩票那
Jake: Reimbursement for scratch-off tickets.
Jake:那你刮出来算啥啊
Jake: What do you get if you scratch it off?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈那那我自费一张20的
Shure: Hahaha, then I'll pay for a 20 myself.
Shure: 来张20的
Shure: Give me a 20.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
其他人:这样吧你给我报
Others: How about you reimburse me?
其他人:50我还刮
Others: I'll scratch off 50 more.
其他人:刮出来钱都是你的
Others: All the money I scratch off is yours.
其他人:哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha
Jake:这么回事
Jake: What's going on?
Shure: 那个打打一注双色打50块钱的双色球
Shure: Let's play a 50 yuan double-color ball.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
其他人:我靠你好老
Others: Wow, you're so old.
其他人:厉害啊哈
Others: Impressive, haha.
Shure: 哈哈号是一哎呀
Shure: Haha, the number is... oh my.
Shure: 那个146
Shure: That 146.
Shure: 啊不不那个红球是146
Shure: No, no, the red ball is 146.
Shure: 然后15二七30 然后篮球是
Shure: Then 15, 27, 30, and the blue ball is...
Shure: 我看一眼算了
Shure: Let me take a look.
其他人:呵这是能算出来吗
Others: Can you really figure it out?
Jake:你别看你看什么菜单啊
Jake: What are you looking at, a menu?
Shure: 篮球双色图
Shure: The double-color ball chart.
Shure: 在哪呢啊
Shure: Where is it?
Shure: 这呢
Shure: Here it is.
Shure: 篮球来一个
Shure: Blue ball, let's pick one.
Shure: 来个5吧
Shure: Let's go with 5.
Shure: 然后5倍对5倍
Shure: Then 5 times, right? 5 times.
Shure: 然后总共30是不
Shure: So, a total of 30, right?
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome.
Shure: 别动
Shure: Don't move.
其他人：给我来一个老板
Others: Give me one, boss.
其他人:那你戴眼镜
Others: Put on your glasses, then.
Jake:不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:不不不这么搞这么搞
Jake: No, no, no, do it this way.
Shure: 30是吧
Shure: 30, right?
其他人:但刮彩票可以很解压
Others: But scratching lottery tickets can be really stress-relieving.
其他人:如果刮出来就更解压
Others: If you win, it’s even more stress-relieving.
其他人:来吧
Others: Come on.
Shure: 来吧过去了啊
Shure: Come on, let’s go.
其他人:刮出来了
Others: Got it.
其他人:刮出来就吸了来
Others: If you win, just take it.
其他人：来
Others: Come on.
其他人:最高奖金80万呢
Others: The top prize is 800,000.
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Lucia:让我看看这个的玩法
Lucia: Let me see how to play this.
Shure: 就刮带这个带这个符号的
Shure: Just scratch the ones with this symbol.
其他人:哦这个符号是刮不出来的
Others: Oh, you can’t scratch this symbol.
Shure: 我觉得还有一个我的号码啊
Shure: I think there's still my number.
其他人:对你先把你的号码刮出来
Others: Yeah, scratch your number first.
其他人:中奖号码你的号码刮出来
Others: The winning number, scratch your number.
其他人:嗯那我也刮这个
Others: Hmm, then I’ll scratch this one too.
Katrina: 哎我也刮一个吧
Katrina: Hey, I’ll scratch one too.
其他人:坏了不行我要忍住
Others: Oh no, I can’t, I need to hold back.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈 1133
Shure: Hahaha, 1133.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：完了
Others: It’s over.
其他人：你这是多少
Others: How much is yours?
其他人：50的
Others: 50.
Jake:哎 50的
Jake: Hey, 50.
Jake:你这为什么更牛逼
Jake: Why is yours better?
Shure: 看起来他50的
Shure: Looks like his is 50.
其他人:来就来大的
Others: Let’s go big.
其他人:你中了吗
Others: Did you win?
Jake:他有几个铲子啊
Jake: How many shovels does he have?
Shure: 草 323134我这是金铲铲
Shure: Damn, 323134, I got the golden shovel.
Jake:就一个铲子 34
Jake: Just one shovel, 34.
Jake:呵呵呵不太像
Jake: Haha, doesn’t look like it.
其他人:他这个没中
Others: He didn’t win.
Shure: 鸡
Shure: Chicken.
其他人:好回本了回本了
Others: Alright, we broke even, we broke even.
Shure: 哦哦回本了回本了
Shure: Oh oh, we broke even, we broke even.
Shure: 回本我们就必须得继续allin
Shure: Now that we broke even, we have to keep going all-in.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
其他人：赌徒啊天啊
Others: Such a gambler, oh my god.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
其他人:他回本了
Others: He broke even.
Shure: 就是这个十一嘛
Shure: It's just this eleven.
Shure: 然后这又是十一
Shure: And then another eleven.
Jake:哦对了21哎
Jake: Oh right, twenty-one.
Shure: 然后就获得这20
Shure: And then you get this twenty.
Jake:哎呦这贵的就是快刮的
Jake: Whoa, the expensive ones are quick to scratch.
其他人: 哦这些这些都能直接换钱
Others: Oh, these can be exchanged for cash directly.
Jake:对啥意思
Jake: Yeah, what do you mean?
Shure: 你好这个中了20
Shure: You just won twenty.
Jake:这刮这么多钱啊
Jake: You can scratch this much money?
Shure: 然后再拿一张20的
Shure: Then get another twenty one.
Jake:哦那给你写个数字干嘛呀
Jake: Oh, so why write a number on it?
其他人:如果有彩就是下面的钱
Others: If there's a prize, it's the amount below.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 这个20
Shure: This twenty.
Jake:是啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人:就是啥也没有
Others: It means nothing.
其他人:就是鸡的意思
Others: It means chicken.
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Hahaha, oh.
Katrina: 还有铁的没
Katrina: Are there any iron ones left?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:啊你这多少钱呢
Jake: Ah, how much is this?
Katrina: 又来一张
Katrina: Another one.
Jake:也是20 也是20
Jake: Also twenty, also twenty.
Shure: 也是20 也是20
Shure: Also twenty, also twenty.
Katrina: 这不好刮是吧
Katrina: This one's hard to scratch, right?
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
其他人:寄了我怎么感觉寄了
Others: I feel like it's sent.
Jake:你这50块钱怎么一
Jake: How can you not win anything with fifty bucks?
Jake:毛都没有
Jake: Not even a hair.
其他人:50块钱寄了
Others: Sent 50 bucks.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:好可以捐到50是吧
Jake: Alright, so we can donate 50, right?
Jake:福利了我已经逐渐忍住捐了
Jake: Great, I've already managed to hold back and donate.
其他人: 我已经逐渐忍住捐了50
Others: I've already managed to hold back and donate 50.
Katrina: 10跟19
Katrina: 10 and 19.
其他人：啊 80万
Others: Ah, 800,000.
Katrina: 什么东西啊这是
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina: 这什么哈哈
Katrina: What is this, haha.
Jake:啊这要看啥呀
Jake: Oh, what are we looking at?
Katrina: 啊不是
Katrina: Oh, no.
Shure: 不是看号
Shure: We're not looking at the number.
Katrina: 这是下边
Katrina: It's the bottom part.
Katrina: 下边才是那个吧
Katrina: The bottom part is the real thing.
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: Gave me a scare.
Shure: 呵呵呵没有没有没有
Shure: Haha, no, no, no.
Jake:哈哈哈发财了是吧
Jake: Haha, did we strike it rich?
Shure: 上面这是这种
Shure: This is just that kind of thing.
Shure: 一般写80万的都不会中的
Shure: Usually, the ones that say 800,000 won't win.
其他人:但我觉得能刮到写80万的也很不容易
Others: But I think even scratching off an 800,000 is pretty impressive.
其他人:已经开始激动了
Others: I'm already getting excited.
Katrina: 不是主要是我只有一个隐形眼镜
Katrina: No, the main thing is I only have one contact lens.
Shure: 哦哎
Shure: Oh, hey.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我看不清啊
Katrina: Haha, I can't see clearly.
Shure: 别别别刮过了
Shure: Don't, don't, don't scratch it too much.
Jake:哦你你这个80万你特地不刮是吧
Jake: Oh, you're not scratching the 800,000 on purpose, right?
Jake:就是你最后再
Jake: So you save it for last.
Jake:呵呵呵你最后等着
Jake: Haha, you're waiting for the end.
Katrina: 我不知道刮出来多少
Katrina: I don't know how much I'll scratch off.
Katrina: 随缘吧我是多少啊
Katrina: Whatever, how much do I have?
Jake:十十是没有
Jake: Ten, ten is nothing.
Shure: 十十是没有
Shure: Ten, ten is nothing.
Katrina: 10和19
Katrina: 10 and 19.
其他人:哇这中奖率好低啊
Others: Wow, the winning rate is so low.
Katrina: 确实图一乐 30
Katrina: Yeah, it's just for fun, 30.
Jake:30哎
Jake: 30, hey.
Katrina: 没是不是
Katrina: Nothing, right?
Shure: 17那是什么呀
Shure: What is 17?
Jake:没7 那是什么呀
Jake: Nothing, what is it?
其他人:最上面那个
Others: The top one.
其他人:万一80万呢
Others: What if it's 800,000?
Shure: 万一就50中了呢
Shure: What if we hit 50?
Jake: 那80万
Jake: Then it's 800,000.
Shure: 14
Shure: 万一80万
Shure: What if it's 800,000?
Jake:80万看看
Jake: 800,000, let's see.
Jake:卧槽我靠
Jake: Holy crap!
其他人:哇塞差一点
Others: Wow, so close!
Jake:差一点差一点
Jake: So close, so close.
Jake:哎差点憋出一个哎
Jake: Almost held my breath, almost.
其他人：坏了搞我也
Others: Oh no, I'm done for too.
其他人：我也有点想坏
Others: I'm feeling bad too.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我来好好好
Katrina: Hahaha, my turn, okay, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：老板来一张这个啊
Others: Boss, take a picture of this.
Katrina: 完了等会他们说我们怎么还不回去
Katrina: Oh no, they'll ask why we're not back yet.
Jake:这里挂一晚上
Jake: We'll stay here all night.
Katrina: 在这挂一晚上
Katrina: Stay here all night.
Jake:哈哈哈老板还有多少张
Jake: Haha, how many more tickets do you have, boss?
Katrina: 哈哈老板还有多少人
Katrina: Haha, how many more people, boss?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈你要干什么
Shure: Haha, what are you up to?
Shure: 哈哈我们经费allin
Shure: Haha, we're going all-in with our budget.
Katrina: 经费全部
Katrina: All the budget.
Shure: 这个要么就明天卷铺盖回家
Shure: Either we pack up and go home tomorrow,
Shure: 要么我们就经费翻倍
Shure: Or we double our budget.
Shure: 好吧来80万
Shure: Alright, let's go for 800,000.
Jake:哈哈 80万是吧
Jake: Haha, 800,000, right?
其他人:哎好久不刮了
Others: Wow, haven't scratched in a while.
其他人:上一次刮可能还是两年之前
Others: The last time we scratched was probably two years ago.
Shure: 哎没了没了没了
Shure: Oh no, it's gone, it's gone, it's gone.
其他人:没了
Others: Gone.
Shure: 彻底GG
Shure: Completely GG.
Lucia:哎呀人均一个
Lucia: Oh no, everyone gets one.
Lucia:那我也买一张吧
Lucia: Then I'll buy one too.
Jake:哈哈哈但我压力很大了哈哈
Jake: Haha, but I'm under a lot of pressure, haha.
Lucia:我也要一张20的嗯
Lucia: I'll take one for 20 as well, hmm.
其他人:4
Others: 4
Shure: 26
Shure: 34这钱放哪里
Shure: Where do we put this 34 bucks?
Jake:这钱上哪领啊
Jake: Where do we collect this money?
Shure: 直接跟跟对
Shure: Just directly, yeah.
Jake:直接直接给是吧哦
Jake: Directly, just give it, right? Oh, okay.
Lucia:我扫您吗
Lucia: Should I scan you?
Lucia:嗯我以为
Lucia: Hmm, I thought...
其他人:看日记没有
Others: Have you seen the diary?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
其他人:没有
Others: No.
Shure: 上次跟你同学去刮针刮出500
Shure: Last time, went with your classmate, scratched and won 500.
Shure: 他说500的是十十
Shure: He said 500 is ten ten.
Shure: 十十十十就是全中那种
Shure: Ten ten ten ten, like, hitting the jackpot.
其他人:哇那很厉害
Others: Wow, that's impressive!
其他人:捐了20福利
Others: Donated 20 to welfare.
Shure: 就一般
Shure: Just average.
Jake:捐20
Jake: Donated 20.
Jake:好嘞福利好
Jake: Alright, welfare is good.
Jake:福利福利
Jake: Welfare, welfare.
Shure: 这个是我们的
Shure: This is ours.
其他人:他中奖率也太低
Others: His winning rate is too low.
其他人:我之前看过有人刮一本
Others: I once saw someone scratch an entire book.
其他人:刮一本算那个算那个钱
Others: Scratching a whole book, counting that money.
其他人:我操又有素材了啊
Others: Damn, more material now.
Lucia:哈哈大家既然都买了我也跟一张
Lucia: Haha, since everyone bought, I'll join with one too.
Shure: 我不会是
Shure: I won't be...
Jake:一个吧那我很难不买了
Jake: One, huh? Then I must buy one.
其他人:那你跟一个
Others: Then you join with one.
Jake:那我跟个20的
其他人:跟个20
Others: Join with a 20.
Jake:这这红的红的和蓝色有什么差别吗
Jake: What's the difference between the red and the blue ones?
Shure: 没有没有区别
Shure: No difference.
Jake:没有差别
Jake: No difference.
Lucia:我觉得我都好久没玩过这个了
Lucia: I feel like I haven't played this in ages.
Jake:好那我选一个
Jake: Alright, I'll pick one.
其他人：哎你这书都很近啊
Others: Hey, your book is really close.
Lucia:哈哈近有什么用呢
Lucia: Haha, what's the use of being close?
其他人：但是但是没什么用啊
Others: But, but it's useless.
其他人：哈哈像刚刚那个
Others: Haha, like that one just now.
其他人：刚刚那个80万其实也很近
Others: That 800,000 just now was also close.
其他人：是吗哈哈哈
Others: Really? Hahaha.
Lucia:哎近有什么用呢
Lucia: Hey, what's the point of being close?
Shure: 近有什么用呢
Shure: What's the point of being close?
其他人:差点差点差点差点就可以光荣的从这里离开了
Others: Almost, almost, almost, we could have left here gloriously.
Jake:整个20了吧
Jake: It's a total of 20, right?
Shure: 20新币的吧
Shure: 20 new dollars, right?
Jake:那不行整个20新币吧
Jake: No, that won't work. A total of 20 new dollars?
Jake:那那可不行
Jake: No, that won't do.
Shure: 杨老板好好理智
Shure: Jake, be rational.
其他人:哎他中奖率好
Others: Hey, his winning rate is good.
Lucia:是感觉小时候的
Lucia: It feels like when we were kids,
Lucia:都比这个中奖率能高一点
Lucia: the winning rate was a bit higher than this.
其他人:我们连买了123四五张
Others: We bought like one, two, three, four, five tickets.
其他人：就你中
Others: Only you won.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Shure: 就我第一张中
Shure: Only my first ticket won.
其他人:对啊这概率有点低是吧哈哈好气
Others: Yeah, the probability is a bit low, right? Haha, so frustrating.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake:来来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: Here it comes, here it comes, here it comes, here it comes.
Lucia:哈哈好气
Lucia: Haha, so frustrating.
Shure: 杨老板相信你
Shure: Jake, I believe in you.
Shure: 好中国有句古话叫做哈哈哈
Shure: Well, there's an old Chinese saying, "Shit, hahaha."
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Shit, shit, hahaha.
Shure: 哎呦杨老板好干脆啊没有
Shure: Wow, Jake, you're so straightforward. Nothing?
Jake:没
Jake: Nothing.
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nothing.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
其他人:哎哦没有
Others: Hey, oh, nothing.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
Shure: 哎呦没有
Shure: Oh, nothing.
Shure: 哎呦没
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
Jake:哎中了30
Jake: Oh, I won 30.
Shure: 是18
Shure: It's 18.
Jake:哎呦哎呦哎呦卖10块
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, sell for 10 bucks.
Shure: 哎呦赚10块
Shure: Oh, made 10 bucks.
Jake:哎呦来看看
Jake: Oh, come and see.
其他人：哎呦赚10块
Others: Oh, made 10 bucks.
Jake:招招18哎
Jake: Winning 18, hey.
Jake:还是23是吧
Jake: Or is it 23, right?
Jake:是2327
Jake: It's 23, 27.
其他人:很难中两个
Other: It's really hard to hit two.
Shure: 很难中两个
Shure: It's really hard to hit two.
其他人:很难中两好
Other: It's really hard to hit two good ones.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人:还刮吗
Other: Are we still scratching?
Jake:不刮了不刮了
Jake: No more scratching, no more.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 哈哈哈你赚10块是吗
Shure: Hahaha, did you make 10 bucks?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:见好见好就收
Jake: Quit while you're ahead.
Jake:见好就收
Shure: 我靠他居然见好就收
Shure: Wow, he really knows when to stop.
Shure: 什么人啊这是他借我
Shure: What kind of person is this, he borrows from me...
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
其他人:投资回报率也太低了
Other: The return on investment is too low.
Shure: 你想靠这个刷ROI是吗
Shure: Are you trying to boost your ROI with this?
Lucia:你想考什么时候关门吗
Lucia: Are you trying to figure out when to close?
Jake:现在就去吧
Jake: Let's go now.
Shure: 现在就去吧快去吧
Shure: Let's go now, hurry up.
Tasha: 应该可以在外
Tasha: Should be able to stay outside.
Jake:就是就在跑隔壁
Jake: Just run next door.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:早知道我们是7点多到
Jake: If we had known, we would've arrived around 7.
Shure: （歌词）为你写诗
Shure: (lyrics) Writing poems for you.
Shure: 哈哈哈怎么了
Shure: Hahaha, what's up?
Shure: 看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure: 我们的500万
Shure: Our 5 million.
Shure: 买这号买了好多好长时间
Shure: Buying this number took a long time.
其他人:哦这个这个这个
Other: Oh, this, this, this.
其他人:你是要相信运气的
Other: You need to believe in luck.
Jake:谢可以在这继续走吧
Jake: Thanks, we can keep going here.
其他人:有些人就是一直买一个号
Other: Some people keep buying the same number.
其他人:然后可能突然有一天没买就真的中
Other: And then one day, they don't buy it and it wins.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 号很好
Shure: The number is really good.
Jake:就那排队的
Jake: It's just the queue.
Tasha: 差不多是高中了
Tasha: Almost in high school.
Jake:他就是在菜鸟驿站没有取
Jake: He didn't pick it up at the rookie station.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Right?
Lucia:呃还有别的地还有别的地
Lucia: Uh, there's another place, there's another place.
Jake:别的地
Jake: Another place?
Lucia:星辰
Lucia: The star place.
Lucia:有一个星辰分布还是啥
Lucia: There's a star distribution or something.
Shure: 京京京东的吗
Shure: Is it JD's?
Lucia:呃我不是京东
Lucia: Uh, I'm not JD.
Lucia:那个雨轩是京东
Lucia: That Yuxuan is JD.
Shure: 京东关了
Shure: JD's closed.
Katrina: 京东我不是京东
Katrina: JD, I'm not JD.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia:哎啊
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia:不是京东
Lucia: Not JD.
Lucia:那应该还能去到
Lucia: Then we should still be able to go there.
Shure: 那行
Shure: Alright.
Jake:那你在这先排
Jake: You queue here first.
Jake:我到前面看看去
Jake: I'll go check in front.
Katrina: 喂你好
Katrina: Hello, hi.
Jake:前面可能还有一个口
Jake: There might be another entrance in front.
Lucia:好啊
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's another one.
Katrina: 嗯嗯然后然后我是那个31号
Katrina: Hmm, hmm, then I'm number 31.
Katrina: 你从那个53往右拐进去
Katrina: Turn right from number 53.
Katrina: 那个绿色房子就是
Katrina: That green house is it.
Katrina: 就在他后面
Katrina: It's right behind it.
Jake:哎走大路看不清楚
Jake: Hey, walking on the main road, I can't see clearly.
Katrina: 呃我们是31号那个绿色的
Katrina: Uh, we're number 31, the green one.
Jake:是他妈在哪来着
Jake: Where the hell is it?
Jake:是有一个小豁口
Jake: There's a small gap.
Jake:这豁口里边有一个你记得不
Jake: There's a place inside that gap, remember?
其他人：哪个
Others: Which one?
Jake:就是我们
Jake: It's where we...
其他人:哦那天后面去那个
Others: Oh, that day we went to the back.
Katrina: 五五十一在我们旁边吗
Katrina: Is 51 next to us?
Jake:对对对一堆保安那个
Jake: Yeah, yeah, the one with a bunch of security guards.
其他人:一堆保安那个
Others: The one with a bunch of security guards.
Shure: 51是从51往那个里面的那个胡同走
Shure: 51 is from 51, go inside that alley.
Katrina: 51
Katrina: 51.
其他人:从51往那个51往里走
Others: From 51, go inside 51.
Katrina: 51往那个胡同走
Katrina: Go into that alley from 51.
其他人:那个我不记得
Others: That one, I don't remember.
其他人:   那个我去过一次
Other: I went there once.
Shure: 然后就是31
Shure: And then it's 31.
Katrina: 然后就是31
Katrina: And then it's 31.
Jake:可能在这或者是在那
Jake: Maybe here or there.
Katrina: 好谢谢
Katrina: Okay, thanks.
Katrina: 麻烦你
Katrina: Sorry to bother you.
Jake:那我先看一眼这然后要不就在那
Jake: Let me take a look here first, or maybe over there.
Katrina: 你放门口就行
Katrina: You can leave it at the door.
Jake:反正是在这附近
Jake: Anyway, it's nearby.
Katrina: 那我们现在去哪
Katrina: So where are we going now?
Katrina: 菜鸟驿站吗
Katrina: To the Cainiao Station?
Shure: 你是在菜鸟驿站吗
Shure: Are you at the Cainiao Station?
Shure: 我那你跟他排队去
Shure: Well, then you go queue up with him.
Katrina: 我呃我是菜鸟驿站
Katrina: I'm, uh, I'm at the Cainiao Station.
Jake:不在这
Jake: Not here.
Jake:找个人问问吧
Jake: Let's ask someone.
Jake:抓个人问问吧
Jake: Let's grab someone and ask.
Jake:美发找美发问问
Jake: Ask someone at the hair salon.
Jake:您好您请问知道百世快递在哪取吗
Jake: Excuse me, do you know where to pick up Baishi Express?
Jake:啊百世快递搁哪啊
Jake: Uh, where is Baishi Express?
其他人：：你看对面有快递点吗
Other: Do you see the pickup point across the street?
Jake:对就是好
Jake: Yes, got it.
Jake:好吧谢谢你
Jake: Alright, thanks.
Shure: 直走左转直走左转好嘞
Shure: Go straight, turn left, go straight, turn left, got it.
Jake:好谢谢好
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Shure: （歌词）没有共产党
Shure: (Lyrics) Without the Communist Party...
Shure: （歌词）就没有新中国
Shure: (Lyrics) There would be no new China. 政治问题
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is this it?
Shure: 看着像
Shure: Looks like it.
其他人：不是吧不长这样我记得不长这样
Other: No, I don't think it looks like this.
Shure: 这不是这不是
Shure: No, it's not.
Shure: 这应该是人家厂房
Shure: This should be someone's workshop.
其他人：这库房啊这是
Other: This is a warehouse.
Jake:哦哦哦OK我要去看一眼
Jake: Oh, oh, okay, I'll take a look.
Jake:看哪都来了
Jake: Look, everyone is coming.
Shure: 干什么你要干什么
Shure: What are you doing? What do you want to do?
Shure: 抓小偷
Shure: Catch the thief.
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure: 抓小偷
Shure: Catch the thief.
Shure: 你真的像那种偷东西去的
Shure: You really look like someone who's about to steal something.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:走位很像啊
Jake: Your movements really look like it.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: （歌词）没有共产党就没新中国
Shure: (Singing) Without the Communist Party, there would be no new China. 政治问题
Jake:这个我们怎么处理啊
Jake: How do we handle this?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈回去要讨论讨论
Jake: Hahaha, we need to discuss this later.
Jake:你这你这条
Jake: This, this part...
Shure: 其实我的眼睛处理方式很简单
Shure: Actually, my way of handling it is very simple.
Shure: deleteall
Shure: Just delete all.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Jake:那你刚才干嘛呢哈哈
Jake: Then what were you doing just now? Haha
Jake:直走左拐
Jake: Go straight and then turn left.
Shure: 这不像了
Shure: This doesn't look like it.
Shure: 这是公厕的
Shure: This is the public toilet.
Jake:啊这这个响这个响
Jake: Ah, this is ringing, this is ringing.
Shure: 挺好挺好
Shure: Pretty good, pretty good.
Shure: 我今天放弃了
Shure: I give up today.
Shure: 我本来是要用那个
Shure: I originally wanted to use that.
Shure: 就是租了个服务器
Shure: I rented a server.
Shure: 然后要在跑一个那个模型
Shure: And then I wanted to run a model on it.
Shure: 因为我那个自己训那个模型不好
Shure: Because the model I trained myself wasn't good.
Shure: 然后哎呦那个租那个贼贼傻
Shure: And renting that was so stupid.
Shure: 他那个下载速度巨慢无比
Shure: The download speed was incredibly slow.
Shure: 然后我那数据集大
Shure: And my dataset was big.
Shure: 然后弄不上去
Shure: So I couldn't upload it.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 白搞了今天
Shure: Today was a waste.
Shure: 只能用假数据了对
Shure: I can only use fake data, right?
Shure: （歌词）我有一个
Shure: (Singing) I have a...
Shure: 真走不动了
Shure: I really can't move anymore.
Shure: 我靠一会回去打车吧
Shure: Let's just take a cab back later.
Shure: 就在这就在这啊
Shure: Right here, right here.
其他人：怎么说
Others: What do you say?
Jake:里边哪个
Jake: Which one inside?
Jake:他说里边有驿站吗
Jake: He said there's a station inside?
Jake:就那个是吧
Jake: That one, right?
Jake:嗯进来了
Jake: Hmm, we got in.
Jake:不敢往前谢彬竹问
Jake: Don't dare to go forward, ask the lord.
其他人：他没进来吧
Others: He didn't come in, right?
Jake:嗯抽烟去了
Jake: No, he went to smoke.
Jake:真的他确实点好
Jake: Really, he sure lights up well.
其他人：我总感觉他一天能吸
Others: I always feel like he can smoke...
其他人：好多根啊
Others: ...a lot of cigarettes a day.
Jake:啊他一天吸几根
Jake: Yeah, how many does he smoke a day?
Jake:他是现在越吸越多
Jake: He's smoking more and more now.
Jake:还是
Jake: Or is it...
Shure: 确实在越吸越多
Shure: He definitely is smoking more and more.
其他人：今天以为大概一天只会吸两三根
Others: I thought he'd only smoke two or three a day.
Shure: 那不是那
Shure: No way, that's not...
Shure: 人家老烟民都是一按盒计的啊
Shure: Real smokers measure by the pack, you know?
其他人：他怎么会对尼古丁耐受呢
Others: How is he so tolerant to nicotine?
Shure: 那肯定
Shure: Of course.
Shure: 就像你喝咖啡就是越喝越没有用
Shure: It's like drinking coffee, the more you drink, the less it works.
Shure: 是一个道理
Shure: Same principle.
Shure: 他现在不至于他可能
Shure: He might not get to that point now, but...
Jake:过过个两年
Jake: Give it another couple of years...
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Yeah, probably.
Shure: 让我们为他默哀
Shure: Let's have a moment of silence for him.
Shure: 啊祈祷
Shure: Ah, a prayer.
Shure: 对祈祷
Shure: Yeah, a prayer.
Shure: 哈哈哈直接默哀
Shure: Hahaha, straight to a moment of silence.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：直接默哀
Others: Straight to a moment of silence.
其他人：直接跳过来
Others: Skipping right over.
Shure: 好哀毕
Shure: Okay, the silence is over.
Shure: 我们这走到哪了
Shure: Where are we heading now?
Jake:哪的这个吗
Jake: This way, right?
其他人：这个这个这个好
Others: This, this, this is good.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:我们绕了一圈是吧
Jake: Did we just go in a circle?
Jake:我们应该有一个口人进来了
Jake: We should have someone come in from here.
其他人：嗯不知道
Others: Hmm, not sure.
Jake:因为我们不是绕了一圈吗
Jake: Because we just went in a circle, didn't we?
其他人：哦确实
Others: Oh, that's true.
Jake:然后如果我们从这边能出去的话
Jake: So if we can go out this way...
Jake:就把性命入大了
Jake: ...we'll be safe.
Jake:然后咱就回来回去了
Jake: Then we'll head back.
Jake:我们来看我们我嗯
Jake: Let's see, we...uhm...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 哎呀他们多少号
Shure: Hey, what number are they?
Jake:那打个电话问问
Jake: Then call and ask.
Jake:我问问
Jake: I'll ask.
Jake:你先打喂喂
Jake: You call first. Hello, hello?
Shure: 喂喂
Shure: Hello, hello?
Shure: 你们在那个百事的那个是什么快递啊
Shure: Which courier service are you at Pepsi?
Shure: 就是另一个
Shure: It's the other one.
Shure: 另一个驿站应该是我的
Shure: The other station should be mine.
Lucia: 应该是我的
Lucia: It should be mine.
Lucia: 呃是那个
Lucia: Uh, it's that one.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Shure: 你再你再单发我一下那个图片吧
Shure: Can you send me the picture again?
Lucia: 行行好嘞好嘞拜拜
Lucia: Sure, sure. Bye-bye.
Shure: 好嘞拜拜
Shure: Okay, bye-bye.
Jake:小绿人
Jake: Green little man.
Shure: 你好9-1-2563
Shure: Hello, 9-1-2563.
Jake:还有顺天快递
Jake: There's also Shuntian Express.
Jake:这么厉害
Jake: So impressive.
其他人：买的什么东西
Others: What did you buy?
Shure: 呃也忘了是哪啥东西
Shure: Uh, I forgot what it was.
Jake:你问他你是啥东西
Jake: Ask him what it is.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Shure: 没了
Shure: That's it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 是不是没有其他的了
Shure: Is there nothing else?
Shure: 没有的话我们就回去了
Shure: If there's nothing else, let's go back.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:问问他们怎么走
Jake: Ask them how to get there.
Jake:哎关门了
Jake: Oh, the door is closed.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:出去比较近那边
Jake: It's closer to go out that way.
Jake:好远远
Jake: So far away.
其他人：从这门这门直接就能出去前面那块有个小门
Others: You can go out directly from this door, there's a small gate in front.
Jake:好谢谢谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks, thanks.
Jake:好好好谢谢谢谢
Jake: Okay, okay, thanks, thanks.
Jake:没有劲道啊
Jake: No strength at all.
Shure: 哎我们把把两个女女生给丢那边了
Shure: Hey, we left the two girls over there.
Jake:那边那边还行
Jake: That side is fine.
Jake:那边还有羊肉串吃
Jake: There's lamb skewers over there too.
Jake:你把人拐这来
Jake: You brought people here.
Jake:倒是有点
Jake: Kind of.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
其他人：太空站有空间
Others: The space station has space.
Jake:什么呀阿巴斯又怎么了
Jake: What's up with Abbas again?
其他人：空间站
Others: Space station.
Jake:有空间
Jake: It has space.
Jake:搜
Jake: Search.
Jake:哇这什么东西
Jake: Wow, what's this?
Jake:杀鸡呢杀鸭杀驴
Jake: Killing chickens, ducks, and donkeys.
其他人:我的脑子还是不如弱智吧的人
Others: My brain is still not as good as a simpleton's.
Shure: 哈哈哈你为
Shure: Hahaha, why do you have to group him with you?
Shure: 什么非得要把他和你化为一类
Shure: Why do you have to put him in the same category as you?
Shure: 你
Shure: You...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 提高记忆力是吗
Shure: To improve memory, right?
Jake:提高逻辑能力
Jake: To improve logical ability.
Jake:逻辑推理能力
Jake: Logical reasoning ability.
Shure: 这棍太粗了不好耍
Shure: This stick is too thick, hard to handle.
其他人: 阿巴斯你知道吗太空有空间站
Others: Abbas, do you know there's a space station in space?
其他人:太挤就没空间站
Others: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 太空有空间
Shure: Space has space.
Shure: 有空空
Shure: It has empty space.
Shure: 有空间站
Shure: It has a space station.
Shure: 太挤就没有空间站了
Shure: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:车辆不上楼
Jake: Vehicles don't go upstairs.
其他人：哎呀走哪去了
Others: Oh no, where did it go?
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Shure: 我们一会穿模了
Shure: We're going to clip through in a bit.
Shure: 我可以把这个
Shure: I can take this.
Jake:哎对头
Jake: Hey, that's right.
Jake:主要是多了个
Jake: Mainly because there's an extra...
Jake:多了个车
Jake: An extra vehicle.
其他人：快饿我都回去
Others: Hurry up, I'm so hungry I could go back.
其他人：应该麦当劳早到了
Others: McDonald's should have arrived by now.
Jake:那给人吃完呢
Jake: Then give it to the people to eat.
其他人：饿死了
Others: Starving here.
Shure: 饿死了
Shure: Starving here.
Jake:那你可等
Jake: Then you can wait.
Jake:等更久行不行呵呵呵
Jake: Wait even longer, okay? Hahaha.
Shure: 我可以边吃边等
Shure: I can eat while I wait.
Jake:啊你吃饱了
Jake: Oh, you are full?
Shure: 没事我会留一点
Shure: No worries, I'll save some.
Shure: 哎呀瞎
Shure: Oops, blind.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
其他人:来北京记得打电话找我
Others: Remember to call me when you come to Beijing.
其他人:我提前把手机关机
Others: I'll turn off my phone in advance.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我靠
Jake: Hahaha, damn.
其他人:嗓子能发出来
Others: Can the voice come out?
Jake:这不是嗓子发的应该
Jake: This shouldn't be from the throat.
其他人:这哪肚子吗
Others: Is it from the stomach?
Shure: 嘴
Shure: Mouth.
Jake:哎这边有小门
Jake: Hey, there's a small door here.
Shure: （歌词）fly me to the moon
Shure: (singing) Fly me to the moon.
Jake:我靠我有个雕像呢
Jake: Damn, I have a statue.
Jake:我靠真他妈像
Jake: Damn, it really looks like it.
Jake:哈哈哈靠这大哥
Jake: Hahaha, damn this guy.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
其他人：他们俩在在那个点等我们吗
Others: Are they waiting for us at that spot?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:或者他们自己回去也不是不可能
Jake: Or they might go back on their own, it's possible.
Shure: 应该会在那等我们吧
Shure: They should be waiting for us there, right?
Jake:我觉得也是
Jake: I think so too.
Shure: 哇好香啊
Shure: Wow, smells so good.
Shure: 闻着不行啊
Shure: The smell is unbearable.
其他人：饿了真饿了
Others: So hungry, really hungry.
Shure: 那俩是吗
Shure: Are those two?
Shure: 那俩不是
Shure: Those two aren't.
其他人：你买的是什么
Others: What did you buy?
Shure: 这不是我买的
Shure: This wasn't bought by me.
Jake:棍
Jake: Stick.
Shure: 对一个圆形长条状物尺
Shure: Yes, a round elongated object, a ruler.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh damn.
Jake:过去过去过去
Jake: Move, move, move.
Shure: 我靠他俩人呢
Shure: Damn, where are those two?
Jake:回去了啊
Jake: They went back.
Shure: 真敢回去啊
Shure: They really went back, huh?
Jake:或者吃串了
Jake: Or maybe they're eating skewers.
Shure: 不能吧
Shure: No way.
Jake:哈哈哈刮刮彩票去了
Jake: Haha, they went to scratch lottery tickets.
Lucia: 没有了就这个
Lucia: No more, just this one.
Lucia: 谢谢你们是在哪边
Lucia: Thank you, where are you guys?
Lucia: 是我和雨轩过去
Lucia: Should Rain and I come over?
Lucia: 还是你们一会还从这条路回来
Lucia: Or are you guys coming back this way later?
Shure: 完了我没看着完了
Shure: Oh no, I didn't see it, it's over.
Jake:晚了回去了
Jake: It's too late, they went back.
Shure: 就互相都不接电话是吧
Shure: So, none of us are answering calls, right?
Shure: 你给雨轩打吧
Shure: You call Rain.
Shure: 喂喂喂你
Shure: Hello, hello, you.
Jake:哪个
Jake: Who?
Shure: 你们在哪
Shure: Where are you guys?
Shure: 你们还在快递站吗
Shure: Are you still at the delivery station?
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Lucia:刚才雨轩还说
Lucia: Rain just said,
Lucia:他们不会又去彩票店了吧哈哈
Lucia: They didn't go to the lottery store again, did they? Haha.
Lucia:我刚接上你电话就网络异常又断了
Lucia: I just connected with your call, then the network went down again.
Shure: 我以为你不接
Shure: I thought you weren't answering.
Shure: 然后就给雨轩打
Shure: So I called Rain.
Shure: 看人家秒接
Shure: He answered immediately.
Shure: 你怎么回事
Shure: What's up with you?
Shure: 反思一下
Shure: Think about it.
Lucia:这不是网络异常吗
Lucia: Isn't it because of the network issue?
Shure: 那他的网络怎么不异常
Shure: Then why didn't his network have issues?
Shure: 怎么全班就你一个人网络异常呢
Shure: Why are you the only one in the whole class with network issues?
Lucia:那我们俩运营商不一样呗
Lucia: Because we use different carriers.
Katrina: 太冲了哈哈哈
Katrina: That's so aggressive, haha.
Shure: 那他怎么知道选那好的运营商
Shure: Then how did he know to choose the good one?
Shure: 你不知道呢
Shure: And you didn't?
Lucia:不是你挑我运营商毛病
Lucia: Are you blaming my carrier?
Lucia:你怎么不去跟运营商对峙一下呢
Lucia: Why don't you go confront the carrier?
Lucia:是吧哈哈
Lucia: Right? Haha.
其他人：顶嘴了是吧
Others: Talking back, huh?
Lucia:你让他你让他把这哈哈哈
Lucia: Let him, let him, haha.
Lucia:你让他把这服务一改进一
Lucia: You should ask him to improve the service a bit.
Lucia:黑我这接你电话就秒接是吧
Lucia: When I answer your calls, I pick up immediately, right?
Lucia:哎呦又掉啊
Lucia: Oh no, it fell again.
Lucia:这玩意已经今天掉了无数次了
Lucia: This thing has fallen countless times today.
Lucia:虽然从我拿上他到现在为止
Lucia: Even though from the time I picked it up until now
Lucia:还不超过10分钟
Lucia: it hasn't even been 10 minutes.
Shure: （歌词）没有共产党哎
Shure: (singing lyrics) Without the Communist Party, hey 政治问题
Katrina: 修硕帮我拿个这个呗
Katrina: Shure, can you help me get this?
Katrina: 因为它滑动摩擦力有点大
Katrina: Because its sliding friction is a bit high.
Katrina: 哇这样就是
Katrina: Wow, like this...
Shure: （歌词）夏天夏天悄悄过去留下小秘密
Shure: (singing lyrics) Summer, summer quietly goes by, leaving a little secret
Shure: （歌词）压心底
Shure: (singing lyrics) Press it down in my heart
Jake:咱也拿点吧
Jake: Let's get some too.
Jake:给咱拿点
Jake: Get some for us.
Shure: 来
Shure: Here.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Katrina: 壁画
Katrina: A mural.
其他人：看起来还是没有狐狸
Others: It still doesn't look like a fox.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:狐狸在哪啊
Lucia: Where's the fox?
Shure: 啊哎
Shure: Ah, hey.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这已经这样子出门了
Katrina: Haha, it's already like this when we go out.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这是围巾
Jake: This is a scarf.
Jake:这是围巾吗
Jake: Is this a scarf?
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina: 围巾要单独买
Katrina: The scarf has to be bought separately.
其他人：狐狸和狐狸的围巾
Others: The fox and the fox's scarf.
Katrina: 围巾还没发货呢
Katrina: The scarf hasn't been shipped yet.
Katrina: 来不及了
Katrina: It's too late.
Jake:这是个烟花吗
Jake: Is this a firework?
Jake:能买烟花吗
Jake: Can we buy fireworks?
Jake:买烟花吧
Jake: Buy fireworks.
Shure: 买烟花
Shure: Buy fireworks.
Jake:买烟花放烟花
Jake: Buy fireworks, set off fireworks.
Katrina: 过年
Katrina: For the New Year.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：你们那里给放烟花吧
Others: You guys can set off fireworks there, right?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 我们今年可以了
Shure: We can this year.
Shure: 前几年都不行
Shure: It wasn't possible a few years ago.
Jake:南洋理工不能放
Jake: Nanyang Technological University can't allow it.
Jake:军事的管制区
Jake: It's a military controlled area.
其他人:但我看之前嘴也不是会放仙女棒啊
Others: But I saw before that Zui didn't set off sparklers either.
Jake:仙女棒算什么东西
Jake: What are sparklers even?
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:啊哪个组委会
Lucia: Ah, which committee?
其他人:所以我好奇
Others: So I'm curious...
其他人:现在他有人陪了
Others: Does he have someone to accompany him now?
其他人:你们过年还会去她家吗
Others: Will you still go to her house for New Year?
Jake:去啊去啊
Jake: Yes, we will.
Jake:只有过年能见到他了
Jake: It's the only time we can see him now.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Jake:就是我老板
Jake: That's my boss.
Jake:就这个给钱的大老板
Jake: The big boss who gives money.
Jake:他这个谈恋爱之前天天跟我们吃饭
Jake: He used to have meals with us every day before he started dating.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:午饭和晚饭都够我们吃
Jake: Both lunch and dinner were enough for us.
Jake:谈恋爱之后就过年见着一次
Jake: After he started dating, we only see him once during New Year.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈他多大年纪啊
Katrina: Haha, how old is he?
Shure: 怎么这个样子呢
Shure: How did this happen?
其他人:所以他他不是刚谈吧
Others: So he's not just starting to date, right?
Jake:没有他他女朋友从美国回来了对
Jake: No, his girlfriend just came back from the US.
其他人：美国America
Others: The US, America?
其他人:居然是America
Others: Really, America?
Shure: 美利坚
Shure: The United States.
Shure: 所以
Shure: So...
Shure: 所以他女朋友是我们这个领域的吗
Shure: So is his girlfriend in our field?
Jake:不算是思科
Jake: Not really, she's from Cisco.
Shure: 什么cisco
Shure: Cisco?
Jake:cisco
Jake: Cisco.
其他人：  Cisco是做
Others: Cisco does...
Shure: 哈哈哈思科
Shure: Hahaha, Cisco.
其他人：非常的形象
Others: Very apt comparison.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Katrina: 啊你好有职业素养啊
Katrina: Ah, you have such professional ethics.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这段
Katrina: Hahaha, this part...
Shure: 这段
Shure: This part
Shure: 说实话
Shure: To be honest
其他人:嗯可以不记
Others: Yeah, no need to remember
Shure: cisco不能叫
Jake:那怎么说
Jake: Then what should we call it?
Shure: 他应该叫
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:这也太要紧了
Jake: That's too serious
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈不行吗
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha, can't we?
Katrina: 好牛啊
Katrina: That's so cool
Shure: 他不如华为啊
Shure: It's not as good as Huawei
Shure: 不行吗行
Shure: Can't we? Sure
Jake:行没问题没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem, no problem
Jake:硬件设备
Jake: Hardware devices
其他人:硬件设备供应商吗
Others: Hardware device suppliers?
Jake:你华为做什么了
Jake: What does Huawei do?
Jake:他不做手机
Jake: They don't make phones
Jake:除了别的
Jake: Besides other things
其他人:这个华为不是
Others: This Huawei isn't
Jake:我靠那什么东西啊我靠
Jake: Oh my, what is that? Oh my
Jake:行我们换个话题好吧
Jake: Okay, let's change the topic, alright?
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe
Shure: 越来越不能播了
Shure: It's becoming less and less broadcastable
其他人:所以所以他
Others: So, so he
其他人:他女朋友回来就要定居在新加坡了
Others: His girlfriend is coming back to settle in Singapore
Jake:是吧哎呀
Jake: Really? Oh my
Shure: 哎呀我今天晚上7点有个会啊
Shure: Oh my, I have a meeting at 7 PM tonight
其他人:牛逼还好
Others: Impressive, lucky
其他人:像我会一般都安排到晚上10点半之后
Others: My meetings are usually scheduled after 10:30 PM
其他人:可是我不会忘了
Others: But I won't forget
Jake:啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Ah, are you still struggling?
Jake:他7点的会还要挣扎吗
Jake: Is he still struggling with the 7 PM meeting?
Jake:也不用了吧
Jake: No need, right?
其他人：你要不讲
Others: If you don't say
Lucia:这不都7:46了吗
Lucia: Isn't it already 7:46?
Jake:对啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Yeah, are you still struggling?
Shure: 我是主持人
Shure: I'm the host
Shure: 我是社长啊
Shure: I'm the president
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哦有人找你是吧
Jake: Oh, someone is looking for you, right?
Lucia:那完了大家已经等了你46分钟了
Lucia: Well, everyone has already been waiting for you for 46 minutes.
Jake:你说你你取快递
Jake: You said you were picking up a package.
Katrina: 你这耍大牌呀
Katrina: You're acting like a big shot.
Jake:取快递取46分钟没问题
Jake: Picking up a package for 46 minutes is no problem.
Katrina: 直接46分钟
Katrina: Straight up 46 minutes.
Shure: 我刚才公司给我突然来了个电话
Shure: Just now the company suddenly called me.
Katrina: 往哪走
Katrina: Where are you heading?
Jake:对对都能走都能走
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you can go anywhere.
Jake:换条新路
Jake: Take a new route.
Shure: 刚Lidar突然给我派了个活
Shure: Lidar suddenly gave me a task.
Shure: 我一下忙忙忙忘了
Shure: I got so busy I forgot.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 他说丽特给他派活了
Katrina: He said Lidar gave him a task.
Katrina: 他忙忘了
Katrina: He got so busy he forgot.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia:确实
Lucia: Indeed.
Katrina: 是啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 丽达让你出来取快递你就说
Katrina: If Lidar asks you to pick up a package, just say so.
其他人:你这样说你就说啊
Others: Just say that, just say that.
其他人:刚才丽特给我呃安排了一下
Others: Lidar arranged something for me.
其他人:明天我们要上线一个party
Others: Tomorrow we have to launch a party.
其他人:刚刚和同事们对齐了一下
Others: Just coordinated with colleagues.
其他人:所以搞的比较晚
Others: So it got a bit late.
其他人:什么行业
Others: What industry?
其他人:黑花
Others: Hei Hua.
Jake:呵你要说特殊情况
Jake: Haha, you need to say it's a special situation.
Jake:见着个狐狸
Jake: Met a fox.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈抓狐狸去了哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, went to catch a fox, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:对对有点不巧
Jake: Yeah, it was a bit unlucky.
Lucia:好冷啊我天
Lucia: It's so cold, my gosh.
Shure: 哎为什么今天吃水饺
Shure: Hey, why are we having dumplings today?
Shure: 不是昨天
Shure: Wasn't it yesterday?
Shure: 是谷雨吧
Shure: It's Guyu, right?
Lucia:希望这几玩意拆开颜色没有色差
Lucia: Hope these things don't have a color difference when opened.
Lucia:要不然我就系了哈
Lucia: Otherwise, I'm going to tie them up.
其他人:那那晚上一般几点钟弄完
Others: So what time do we usually finish at night?
Jake:这个很难讲
Jake: It's hard to say.
其他人:还有一场吗
Others: Is there another match?
Jake:今晚没了
Jake: No more tonight.
Jake:今晚就收拾收拾嘛
Jake: Just cleaning up tonight.
Jake:拆拆快递嘛
Jake: And unpacking some deliveries.
Jake:随便拍拍嘛
Jake: Taking some random shots.
Shure: 哦对不起
Shure: Oh, sorry.
Shure: 因为古语好像有什么打香椿这个
Jake:你可以约
Jake: You can arrange it.
Jake:你随便什么时候约
Jake: Anytime you want.
Shure: 这个习俗
Shure: This custom.
其他人:是啊他爷爷不就说嘛
Others: Yeah, his grandpa said it.
其他人:孩子长大了
Others: The kid has grown up.
其他人:等他回到家那个
Others: When he gets home
其他人:跟他回去
Others: Go back with him.
Katrina: 这还挺漂亮哈
Katrina: This is quite pretty, huh?
Shure: 你跑到哪玩去了今晚
Shure: Where did you go to play tonight?
其他人:台球啊哈哈
Others: Pool, haha.
其他人:我的台球是
Others: My pool game is
Shure: 我可以
Shure: I can
Shure: 我帮你整治
Shure: I can help you fix it.
Jake:啊工作不饱和啊
Jake: Ah, the work isn't saturated.
Shure: 刘帅好吧
Shure: Choiszt, alright?
Jake:工作不饱和
Jake: The work isn't saturated.
Jake:看着
Jake: Look.
其他人:什么叫工作不饱和
Others: What does it mean that the work isn't saturated?
Lucia:还有时间打台球
Lucia: Still have time to play pool.
其他人:啊昨天已经过饱和了
Others: Ah, yesterday it was already oversaturated.
其他人:好嘞你知道我整个人都快要结晶了
Others: Alright, you know I almost crystallized.
Lucia:结晶了哈哈哈
Lucia: Crystallized, hahaha.
Jake:呵呵你这是怎么讲
Jake: Haha, what do you mean by that?
Jake:脱水了是吗
Jake: Dehydrated, right?
Shure: 那个是那什么台球海底捞吗
Shure: Is it that pool hot pot?
其他人:妈的台球海底捞
Others: Damn, pool hot pot.
Shure: 台球海底
Shure: Pool hot pot.
Shure: 嗯台球台球海底捞
Shure: Yeah, pool, pool hot pot.
其他人:台球海底捞
Others: Pool hot pot.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
其他人:这么牛逼啊
Others: So awesome?
Shure: 没事了没事了
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
其他人:也不贵不贵
Others: Not expensive, not expensive.
其他人:就是正常价
Others: It's just the normal price.
Jake:哎我们要拐了
Jake: Hey, we need to turn.
其他人:那这种台阶
Others: These kinds of steps...
Lucia:在这拐
Lucia: Turn here.
其他人:都不会把别人杀的毫无还手之力
Others: ...won't leave people completely defenseless.
其他人:哎这边这边不往前走两下都行
Others: Hey, this way, this way. You don't have to go forward.
Lucia:还是停一下
Lucia: Let's stop for a bit.
其他人:都行吗要不就晚了
Others: Is that okay? Otherwise, it'll be too late.
Jake:这边拐可以啊
Jake: We can turn here.
Jake:那就这么拐吧
Jake: Let's turn this way then.
其他人:百球小生会观察你
Others: The ball player will observe you.
Shure: 我一会去群里说一下
Shure: I'll mention it in the group later.
其他人:你要是这一球要用上加盖了
Others: If you need to use the cap for this ball...
Shure: 实在不好意思
Shure: I'm really sorry.
其他人:他主动帮你把加盖抬起来
Others: He'll help you lift the cap.
其他人:我双手递给你
Others: I'll hand it to you with both hands.
其他人:那加盖用完了
Others: The cap is used up.
其他人:那双手递回来
Others: I'll hand it back with both hands.
其他人:那别的排气
Others: Then exhaust the air.
其他人:那别的排球生存空间在哪呢
Others: Where's the living space for other volleyball players?
其他人:我不知道啊
Others: I don't know.
其他人:我以后肯定只去银川
Others: I'll definitely only go to Yinchuan in the future.
其他人:太逆天了
Others: It's too amazing.
其他人:对于一个小城市出来的我
Others: For someone from a small town like me...
其他人:我去哈哈哈
Others: I'm going, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 他那特贵
Shure: It's really expensive there.
其他人:留下一部位
Others: Save a spot.
其他人:留下京爷就比较会享受啊
Others: Jingye will enjoy it more.
其他人:他说下次
Others: He said next time...
Shure: 79一小时
Shure: 79 an hour.
其他人:他说下次带我去个更好的地方
Others: He said next time he'll take me to a better place.
其他人:哦不是你可以美谈美观啊
Others: Oh, you can talk about it.
其他人:确实今天要坐一下刘帅
Others: Today, we need to sit with Choiszt.
其他人:让我让我看看刘帅开奔驰是什么样子
Others: Let me see how Choiszt drives a Mercedes.
其他人:但是开奔驰的人会不会变帅
Others: But will driving a Mercedes make him look cooler?
Shure: 我靠他那个后排的空间巨大
Shure: Wow, the back seat space is huge.
Shure: 真就是给老板坐的巨爽
Shure: It's really comfortable for the boss.
Shure: 而且你后排是可以调前排座椅的
Shure: And you can adjust the front seats from the back.
Shure: 哈哈哈好
Shure: Hahaha, good.
Jake:哈哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahahaha, okay
其他人:非常的人性化
Others: Very humanized
Shure: 不会像那个捷达
Shure: Not like that Jetta
Shure: 你连找找都找不着
Shure: You can't even find it
其他人:我的手就是找条达到胳膊
Others: My hand is like trying to reach for an arm
Shure: 一看就没开过
Shure: Looks like you've never driven one
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 少爷就是没开过这种手动咔咔咔的车
Shure: The young master has never driven a manual car
Shure: 哎太金贵了少爷
Shure: Oh, too precious, young master
Shure: 大奔驰手动挡是肯定自动
Shure: A big Mercedes manual must be automatic
其他人：这年头的手动挡我都不会开了
Others: These days, I can't even drive a manual anymore
其他人：我感觉没有学法减分我马上就要回去学手动挡的车了
Others: I feel like if there weren't any penalty points, I'd immediately go back to learn manual driving
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia:好冷啊
Lucia: It's so cold
Lucia:这灯的配色也太
Lucia: The color scheme of this light is so...
Jake:撞色
Jake: Contrasting
Lucia:也行吧
Lucia: It's alright
Jake:哈哈独特的设计
Jake: Haha, it's a unique design
Katrina: 就是刚刚那个happy birthday
Katrina: That "happy birthday" just now
Jake:给他唱一段
Jake: Sing it for him
Jake:不像
Jake: Doesn't look like it
Lucia:轰趴
Lucia: House party
其他人:喝酒喝吐了
Others: Drank until they puked
其他人:只喝一分钟
Others: Only drank for a minute
其他人:必须用英语交流
Others: Must communicate in English
Lucia:那只要沉默1分钟就好了
Lucia: Then just stay silent for a minute
其他人：这就京爷的生活
Others: This is the life of a Beijing lord
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Shure: 香椿天妇罗
Shure: Toona tempura
Shure: 我天
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 哎sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry
Shure: 一般那粥都得自己加
Shure: Usually, you have to add it yourself
Shure: 北方这边默认都不加什么糖什么东西
Shure: In the north, they usually don't add sugar or anything
Shure: 然后所以小我就特不爱喝这种粥啥的
Shure: So I really don't like drinking this kind of porridge
Jake:北京能看到星星
Shure: 通州沙河都能看到星星
Shure: You can see stars in Tongzhou and Shahe
Jake:哦不是北京是吧
Jake: Oh, not Beijing, right?
Shure: 哎能能能
Shure: No, no, you can
Shure: 不不这算
Shure: No, it counts
Shure: 北京这这场地也记一下
Shure: Beijing, this location, let's note it down
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 他试图分裂北京呵
Shure: He's trying to divide Beijing, haha.
其他人：不如你那个
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Shure: 呵
Shure: Heh
Jake:就你这个迹象哈哈哈
Jake: Just this sign, haha.
Shure: 然后我小时候吃这种
Shure: When I was a kid, I ate this kind of stuff.
Shure: 然后家长还不让加
Shure: And my parents wouldn't let me add anything.
Shure: 我们家基本什么东西都不让加
Shure: Our family basically didn't allow adding anything.
Shure: 糖什么的
Shure: Like sugar.
Shure: 就觉得不健康
Shure: They thought it was unhealthy.
Jake:说他
Jake:梅开二度
Jake: Scored again.
Jake:梅开三度
Jake: Scored a hat-trick.
Jake:帽子戏法了
Jake: Hat trick.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:帽子戏法
Lucia: Hat trick.
Jake:哈哈哈炸死你
Jake: Hahaha, blow you up.
Jake:哈哈pentakill
Jake: Haha, pentakill!
Shure: 我的伤悲胜过了一些
Shure: My sadness surpasses some others.
Katrina: 往哪走
Katrina: Where to go?
Katrina: 直走
Katrina: Go straight.
Shure: 直往哪走来着
Shure: Which way straight again?
Katrina: 直走吧
Katrina: Just straight.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Jake:都行呵呵呵
Jake: Anything is fine, hehe.
Katrina: 都行
Katrina: Anything is fine.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehehehehehehehe
Jake:走走了造吧哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's create, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈这话简直难以置信
Katrina: Haha, this is just unbelievable.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈难以置信
Lucia: Haha, unbelievable.
Lucia:哈哈哈总能到吧
Lucia: Haha, we'll get there eventually.
Jake:总能总能到吧
Jake: We will, we'll get there eventually.
Lucia:哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Pull back from the brink.
Lucia:那个50
Lucia: That 50.
Shure: 这脑子呀
Shure: Oh, this brain of mine.
Shure: 我天呐一天啥事都记不住
Shure: Oh my god, I can't remember anything in a day.
Shure: 我就昨天
Shure: Just yesterday...
Shure: 应该加提醒式让再加个闹钟的
Shure: I should have set a reminder, maybe another alarm.
Katrina: 定闹钟我现在干啥事都定闹钟
Katrina: Set an alarm, I set one for everything I do now.
Lucia:看看我们现在到哪
Lucia: Let's see where we are now.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 哎呦喂真服了
Shure: Oh wow, I'm really impressed.
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 哎我天呐
Shure: 脑子呀脑子啊
Shure: My brain, oh my brain.
Katrina: 我的隐形眼镜终于可以
Katrina: I can finally wear my contact lenses.
Shure: 快长脑子吧
Shure: Hurry up and grow a brain.
Katrina: 哎累了
Katrina: Ugh, I'm tired.
Jake:确实来给你们吃
Jake: Indeed, here, have some food.
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 好香啊哇
Katrina: Smells so good, wow.
Jake:什么货哦
Jake: What did we get?
其他人：要加班喽
Others: Looks like we have to work overtime.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 哎呀不应该
Shure: Oh no, shouldn't have.
Katrina: 我终于可以戴眼镜了
Katrina: I can finally wear glasses.
Jake:吃吃汉堡吃蛋挞
Jake: Eat burgers and egg tarts.
Shure: 吃汉堡
Shure: Eat burgers.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake:蛋挞是吧
Jake: Egg tarts, right?
Shure: 嘘帅帅师傅
Shure: Shh, Shure the master.
Jake:好有什么好的吗
Jake: Alright, anything good?
其他人：你们有人点了那个脆脆薯条吗
Others: Did anyone order those crispy fries?
Jake:有有有好的甜品吗
Jake: Yes, yes, any good desserts?
Shure: 我是一个巨无霸
Shure: I'm a Big Mac.
其他人:如果没有人点的就是我点的
Others: If no one ordered it, then I did.
其他人:但是我忘了你点的
Others: But I forgot what you ordered.
Katrina: 买成日抛了我操
Katrina: I ended up buying daily disposables, damn.
Tasha:要吃个肉松小贝吗
Tasha: Do you want a meat floss cake?
Shure: 就是你
Shure: It's you.
Shure: 回去说说我妈去
Shure: I'll go tell my mom.
Jake:菠菠萝要
Jake: Pineapple, yes.
Shure: 怎么不给修硕这孩子吃糖啊
Shure: Why don't you give Shure some candy?
Jake:可以要啊煎呗
Jake: Sure, go ahead and fry it.
Shure: 你看他都没长个
Shure: Look, he hasn't grown at all.
Shure: 就是吃糖吃少了
Shure: It's because he didn't eat enough candy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:吃吃吃吃
Jake: Eat, eat, eat.
Jake:严谨严谨
Jake: Be meticulous.
Jake:吃点什么呢
Jake: What should we eat?
Lucia:哪个是我的来着
Lucia: Which one is mine?
Lucia:我又忘了
Lucia: I forgot again.
Jake:没关系盲盒麦当劳盲盒
Jake: No worries, it's a McDonald's blind box.
Lucia:麦当劳盲盒
Lucia: McDonald's blind box.
Jake:对麦当劳盲盒
Jake: Yes, McDonald's blind box.
其他人：去了差不多一个小时了
Others: It's been almost an hour.
Jake:因为路就很远
Jake: Because the road is very far.
Alice:走路去的吗
Alice: Did you walk there?
Lucia:这个好像是牛奶
Lucia: This seems to be milk.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:是吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia:哪个是哪个是
Lucia: Which one is which?
Lucia:好巧克力
Lucia: Oh, chocolate.
Lucia:那这个应该是热巧克力吧
Lucia: Then this should be hot chocolate.
Alice:饮品在这里
Alice: The drinks are here.